et on regarde des événements
consternants advenu ce matin à
l'Assemblée c'est avec une profonde
gravité que je m'adresse à vous
madame la Première ministre les droits
des oppositions politiques sont le
fondement même de la démocratie c'est à
l'aune de ses droits qu'on juge la
qualité d'une démocratie pour tous nos
partenaires européens régime
parlementaire rompu à la négociation et
à une certaine culture du compromis
notre régime politique est une
incongruité pour ne pas dire une
aberration ou le gouvernement avance en
écrasant toute contestation devant lui
ce matin c'est bien plus que la bataille
de retraite qui est jouée à l'Assemblée
nationale en torpillant une initiative
parlementaire de l'opposition en
bafouant le droit d'amendement en
transformant le corset de l'article 40
en véritable étau vous créez un
précédent délétère qui menace de réduire
à néant le droit d'expression déjà
famélique des parlementaires madame la
Première ministre vous êtes une
démocrate vous l'avez clamé ici même en
juillet 2022 comment pouvez-vous tolérer
la dérive autoritaire dans laquelle le
président vous enferme
l'examen de la réforme des retraites a
eu lieu avec 175 heures de débat
parlementaires elle a été votée par deux
fois par le Sénat et le Conseil
constitutionnel s'est prononcé très
clairement sur la conformité de
l'essentiel du texte à notre
Constitution et sur le rejet de deux
demandes de référendum d'initiative
partagée qui visait à l'abroger la
proposition doit dont vous parlez qui
fait actuellement l'objet d'un examen
par la commission des affaires sociales
de l'Assemblée nationale
aggraverait considérablement les charges
publiques et réduirait les recettes cela
contrevient de façon évidente à
l'article 40 de notre Constitution ce
texte vous le savez monsieur le
Président est anticonstitutionnel et
personne n'est dupe de la manœuvre qui
se joue
et monsieur le Président Gothard vous
appelez au respect du Parlement au débat
je vous renvoie à ces principes ce matin
la commission des affaires sociales de
l'Assemblée nationale a voté et à
supprimer l'article de la proposition de
loi qui visait à abroger la réforme des
retraites c'est un vote clair et
démocratique mais immédiatement après
laupes a répondu par l'obstruction avec
le dépôt de 3000 sous amendements pour
empêcher un vote final en commission
la réalité c'est que lorsque le résultat
d'un vote déplaît à la nupasse elle n'a
qu'une réponse l'obstruction alors je
souhaite que l'examen de la proposition
de loi puisse aller à son terme dans de
bonnes conditions et que le contrôle de
la recevabilité des amendements puissent
exercer normalement dans la série unité
en somme je ne souhaite qu'une chose le
respect de nos règles et du débat
parlementaire je vous remercie madame la
Première ministre d'abord l'obstruction
c'est vous toute ordre les règles ce
n'est pas appliqué les règles madame le
Premier ministre vous pouvez entrer dans
l'histoire en ouvrant une page nouvelle
de notre république parlementaire vous
auriez entrerez hélas comme une
Fossoyeuse de la démocratie française
[Musique]